[Music]
in thankless rescue news oh you should
get a whole attack ad somewhere in
Jamali because it's submitted by Tyco
and Joe Mallya whoa what are you doing
over there I'll be back it's my vacation
it keeps him from like being born yeah
it's PI tired it was as I was a long
trip
a woman was scalded by police after
helping to rescue a child from a burning
truck what no what was this what if they
were all there the policemen were there
firemen were there they were about to
jump issues no and then she like is
there video no video it sounds like the
perfect article that have a video to go
with it yeah her name is tequila her
name is tequila Isaacson interesting
she's a truck driver
this woman is the key blossom character
what's your last name
Isaacson Isaacson and she has like the
smoothest skin in the world your
eyebrows that it disappeared into the
skin and then her style looks like she
could be from like anything between 80s
90s like I can't pinpoint it well she's
a hero way to go to Cuba
she looks like Dwight's sister anyways
uh so she hit tequila she posted this on
her Facebook oh that's a lot of [ __ ]
ladder
[Laughter]
so it's she's just pretty much saying
she's venting out how that night she was
on her way home from Washington they
stopped by a rest stop and that's when
she saw a pickup truck that was towing a
pickup truck and they came to a stop it
burst into flame oh sure
her boyfriend or whoever she was with
started calling 9-1-1 she was saying
that there was three people in the truck
two adults and a child with two adults
we're trying to get the child out of the
truck and so she went on to go look for
a fire extinguisher at this rest stop
but there were no fire extinguishers
anywhere to be found until she found one
inside of a coffee shop sort of thing
and so but there's a glass door
I was blocking her and the fire
extinguisher so what she did is she
grabbed something she broke the glass
she grabbed the fire extinguisher she
was able to put out the fire save the
kid and then all that took less than
three minutes Wow
but then when the cops got there they
started like scolding her that she
shouldn't have broken the thing and now
they're telling her that she has to pay
for it for the damage on the glass door
and as she's being threatened with
burglary charges
she live in China know this happen in
Washington Oh was it really not that
life-threatening where the cops come up
and they're like oh dude you didn't have
to do all that [ __ ] no it was
life-threatening because she said that
the truck was on fire to the point where
when she finally found the fire
extinguisher and she looked at the truck
she couldn't see the kid anymore because
the flames took over it like they were
coming from under the bed so it was just
like the whole truck was nothing what
about the driver
well the two parents are trying to get
the kid out that's right they needed a
way to put out the fire to get the kid
out does the kid still have his eyebrows
I'm not sure because if he doesn't and
it's burnt off then yes it was imminent
danger yeah
but if the kid was like cold still I
need a sweater then he probably wasn't
in a fire I like how you say eyebrows
versus like any body part like your skin
or like your actual eyebrows are the
first fire test are they yes I would
think clothes maybe like burns on your
skin but I'm sure I both know Chinese
cooks don't have eyebrows mm-hmm cuz
we're playing with the wok on me you
talk about a Chinese eyebrows you know
those Kung Fu eyebrows that go up right
here like like that yeah do you guys
think you're gonna get those I don't
know not actually want it it goes up
like that and it goes down like there's
a it's it's like a little visor only
generals have them yeah movies
I got some crazy ass [ __ ] it's
always the guy that it comes out and
then he's like the bald guy with in his
[ __ ] Chinese kimonos like exposed cuz
he's like the strong one lucky and he's
the one with the broad sword with the
rings that's pierced oh yeah or earrings
in there does that translate well in
today's fashion sense why not no okay I
don't wanna wait so she crawled through
that hole no isaacsohn your aura
she broke back she broke that to get the
fire station so she's saying that in
this photo you can see this little clip
and that's where the fire extinguisher
was so she grabbed it are they saying
like well this is a private
establishment like who's gonna pay for
these damages seems like what that is
but she like her thing is like how the
[ __ ] they're not gonna have a fire
extinguisher at a rest stop like isn't
that something that should be accessible
do they have them at I don't know if
I've already even paid attention I don't
think I'm ever I'm always half asleep
going I just need any cleaner bathrooms
at rest stops that's what they need yeah
that [ __ ] got Dookie all over graffiti
and toilet paper you need it always bad
there's never toilet paper and there's
just like metal toilets with no toilet
seats
what the how are you supposed to take a
[ __ ] on that yeah like Americans led us
to that because we can't take care of
anything you go to any public restroom
they all look like [ __ ] cuz we can't
take care I'm not the guy that poops on
the toilet seat there's a lot of guys
that [ __ ] on the toilet seat I don't
know how it lands there but there's
sometimes Dookie on the toilet seat but
the hole so big how do you hover and I
don't all they must be like waiting for
the very last second they're like oh
drop the pants and then wherever it goes
it goes or maybe didn't wait there but
like clean enough that it just smears
skidmark like a smell so she started a
GoFundMe because she said that I got the
end of her pose what wait the parents
didn't even defend for her for getting
their kid out no as the cops in the
firefighter like they know the whole
story but they're still threatening to
charge her with burglary
about the parents helping her pay for it
because they are you like just telling
the cops like hey can you just drop the
charges because they actually saved me
it's not a charge that the parents yeah
yeah so she run at the under her post
since since so many people have
requested a go fund me one was created
the amount is arbitrary the total cost
is not yet known and I don't know if it
caps off once the amount is reached it
makes me kind of not want to be a good
person and help people anymore if that's
the if that's a banks you get the sound
like a California story I was a
Washington you section what what city or
what's the biggest cattle where this
happened it was at a rest stop and never
mind try and knock while me a pass
Washington I remember when I burned a
SUV in the garage and me and can and
Tommy we put out the fire and then when
the fire department came they called us
heroes because we did all the work like
thanks for coming and he's like you guys
are the heroes today that was all you
guys it's probably cuz you didn't steal
that fire extinguishers Oh
anything that wasn't yours that's true
our neighbors fire extinguisher came to
the rescue
well they're the heroes yeah oh we
should buy a fire extinguisher we have
one in our house we have two here we do
we'd have the sprinkler system no boy
those malfunction
yes brink where sizzling oh yeah you
should have one in wait so what if
you're like start cooking something
smoking my that's the melt will be hot
enough for the caps cuz it has like
these cap systems so once that melts
then it pops it's localized so like if
you have a fire that the caps it
prevents everything from going off at
once so if your living rooms on fire
only the living room goes off oh that's
tiny then the new homes have that stuff
it's pretty cool feel so bad for this
lady so what was it like a restaurant or
it was some sort of business oh yeah it
was like a coffee shop is your shop out
of us I mean are they the ones then that
should be putting this charger removing
it because I feel like why would the
cops be like overstep being kind of I
feel like and then being like yeah like
that's burglary but then if the
restaurants like well not really like we
would have like it's cool that they did
that we don't care like that we put the
fire extinguisher close to the doors
yeah
yeah that's true if I was the business I
would have been like we'll pay for it I
don't care yeah sure it's a kid was
saved like you did a good thing you know
I'd come and not [ __ ] free coffee on
us yes alright be like you up I'll pay
for it and don't forget to stop by Hanks
coffee next time you're in I think she
actually did the least amount of damage
cuz I would have looked at that glass of
door and ran my car through then grabbed
it and then ran back out and then yeah
it's I think it would have been way
different yeah mom the whole thing is
you should do punch the [ __ ] glass
maybe get a rock yeah that was the mom
that has too much movement I would have
thought it yours because that would have
been like what can I do to not damn make
more than a big in life or death
remember were thought we're thinking
about getting that lady out of the pool
we're like bars gonna drive all I shoot
the [ __ ] pull up lady that was stuck
in a pool above ground pool and she got
stuck somehow cuz the ladder broke so
she couldn't get out so our superhero
team would go but cause more damage yeah
and just shoot at the full thing break
yeah sorry solution yep hope you guys
enjoyed that episode of JK news make
sure to stay connected because we're
constantly updating our social media so
follow us at JK films for Instagram and
at JK films for Twitter to watch more
videos click right over here
[Music]